hannah is the person that I've always  wanted to be she just feels like I'm  missing a piece to my life you have to  have that wanted in early connection  with someone to really make things work  and I really do believe that we have  that I've never felt this intensely for  someone i 100% you can see this woman is  my wife like 100% I have three amazing  men say me in front of me and this week  has been amazing you've opened your  heart to me their families  you've been vulnerable and honest and  open and I just feel so blessed but I  have to continue to make the hard  decisions that makes this hard for me  because I'm not just breaking somebody's  heart breaking my heart  [Music]